[MUSIC]
All right.
Welcome everybody.
Now that folks Are able to join the room
is so great to be here with you.
My name is Wil I'm one of
the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
So we are going to talk a little
bit about what is a story?
I think as I work with people
sometimes I hear that the phrase,
I'm comfortable my story, I know my story,
but what does that even mean?
And what does the story have to do
with applying to business school?
From there, I do have some
exercises to get us a kickstart.
So maybe you are already
well in the weeds.
Some of these exercises can help you maybe
think through things from a new direction,
kind of that spirit of innovation,
let's step back, trying new things and
see how that broadens our view of stuff.
For those of you who might be exploring or
are unsure, I have some exercises for
you as well that might be able to
help you start to crystallize and
give some resolution to
the things that you might
be hoping to achieve at
business school and beyond.
After the exercises,
we'll be tying it back to your journey and
then I would love to close with some tips,
takeaways,
especially on that
practical tactical sense.
So that while we're also talking about
the process, we're thinking about
how we can equip you so that you can
put your best foot forward, okay.
So preface, you are going to see and
hear a ton of advice out there.
And some of it is, well meaning some of
it is also, maybe shrouded in a little
mystery and maybe it's also shrouded
in a little bit of misinformation.
Take anything with a grain of salt.
There is no one right or
wrong way to apply to business school.
Even the things that I'm sharing with
you today they are not end of the story,
rulebook of things that you need
to do to get into Stanford, but
rather some tips, tricks,
exercises that you can do to help maybe
kick start your process or
get you get that momentum back if you've
run into like some writer's block and
need some inspiration.
Okay, so hopefully these are tools
that you can use to self coach.
One of my other big goals in this role is
to help provide the information that you
need so that you can put your best
foot forward, so that you understand
the process, so that we can embrace
kind of this whole journey together.
Next up, so what is a story and
what does it have to do with
the business school application.
So, at its most fundamental level,
I think about the quote unquote story or
your personal narrative as expression
of your motivation for business school.
Very open ended.
And this is just one interpretation.
I know there are many others out there and
even as we head forward, I can only speak
on behalf of the things at Stanford, other
schools might have other opinions as well.
But again, tool sets and
kits to hopefully help you think broadly,
think big about this process.
So well, okay, there's a story.
There's a personal narrative but
am still applying the school like,
yes, and applying to a professional
school is kind of different,
slightly different experience.
And I think this is something even I
didn't really appreciate until working in
this space.
For many academic programs,
that program and that degree in and
of itself is part of the goal,
learning and in the case of PhDs,
creating knowledge and
adding to our understanding of the world.
For professional schools,
think law schools, medical school,
business school, you're often attending
school towards some goals for
some application of that learning and
knowledge.
In our case,
it's that realm of business and
I personally think that the term business
school is a little bit of a misnomer
because we're going to be equipping you to
lead in almost any organizational context.
Oftentimes, it's in the business setting,
there are business elements that you might
be also able to use in
other parts of your life.
So it is this broad experience to help
you thrive wherever you end up next.
So that's kind of how I see it.
I know there's a lot of other
interpretations of it, but
at business school,
the horizons really open for you.
You're going to get asked two questions
wherever you go, two fundamental questions
that we can start with here, so
why business school, why now?
And what are your short term and
long term goals?
So I know some of you out
there are still working on,
like figuring out what
some of those details are.
And that's wonderful.
That's what we're here
to help you with today.
As you take a look at
the Stanford application,
you're going to notice that we're also
going to be asking you to look backwards.
What are the experiences you've had?
What did you do?
Who are you now because of it?
One of the philosophies that we hold
dear is in the application process,
especially past behavior
can be a great indicator
of how you might behave
perform again in the future.
So in addition to that projection forward
of what you want to do in the future, we
also are asking you to look back, reflect
and understand your journey to today.
The other piece here is that
reflective piece and looking inwards.
And I think this is one of those things
that when people start the GSB application
they don't always understand,
what will happen as part of the journey.
So making sure to build in some extra time
for that is going to be a key tips that I
have regardless of what stage of
application you're thinking in.
So let's dig a little bit more deeply,
but as we do that, I think there is
also that conception, here you're
going to see a lot of squiggles.
You often hear of hey,
this is my journey, I feel good about it.
The assumption that there is some
linear path to business school,
when in reality it's going to
be different for everyone.
That's where these wiggles come into play.
Sometimes there's ups, downs,
forwards, backwards, and
as you embrace that understand how
that path has shaped who you are.
I personally think that helps set you up
better not just for the business school
application process, but as you think
forward to your career and life ahead.
Okay, some squiggles, some lines.
I'm a very visual person.
So what are some other ways
to think through this?
So I have, of course, another visual here.
So anchoring on these two questions,
why business school,
why now and what are your short term and
long term goals?
The story of who you are can take so
many directions,
but these two will help us figure out
okay, where is a good starting point?
And who is the audience that we're
already starting to think about?
Think about this journey.
As a journey and
that is one of those analogies you're
going to hear pretty frequently.
And it's the narrative around this journey
that we're going to be spending our
attention on today.
To answer these questions, we're often
very focused on just that hearing now that
path, that walkway and maybe that
immediate environment that surrounds it.
But what happens if
the questions are different?
What if we're asking you
tell us about a time when?
And in the GSB application you are
going to see a couple of things like that.
There are optional short response
questions, tell us about time when your
background or lived experience
influenced an interaction you've had, or
tell us about time where
you've had impact?
Right, what are the steps that
got you to where you are today?
What does that path look like?
What was, again, that environment
surrounding that journey that
informed where you were able to move and
kind of flow through life, okay?
What if the question is about
what your values or mission?
Dee Moss does talk a lot about how there
is a body of research out there that shows
some of the most successful leaders are
those that lead from a place of mission
and values.
What are yours?
Or maybe it's a question about,
think big, what's out there?
What is it that you aspire towards?
I think there is some element of
aspiration that all of our business
schools, regardless of where you're
looking, are hoping to inspire and
instill and help you bring to life.
And so let's lift our head up from that
trail to look at that blue sky and
think there.
And then, okay,
lots of different ways we can take that.
So as we talk through this,
hopefully I'm going to take us away from
individual answers as we start to
construct your personal narrative.
So think about the big picture,
how do we go from individual questions and
answers to understanding here
are the connections in my life?
If someone asks you to look to the left,
right, up, down,
are you going to be able to
answer those with detail and
feel good about that and
come from a place of owning that journey?
That is that transition that I
hope we're able to make today and
really inform the way we think about
telling your story moving forward.
All right, so starting your story,
what's on your horizon?
So this is where we're looking forward.
We're going to look forward and
look back during today's session.
So if you haven't done so
already or if you have one handy,
I encourage you to find a pen,
or some paper, or
maybe open up another browser
window where you can type along.
If you don't have any of that handy,
just think through things along with us.
For those of you who might be watching
this on replay in the future,
hello from the past,
I'll be giving you some cues for
a time where you might be able to pause,
so that you can extend the time and
customize these exercises
to have them work for you.
I'll give you some additional cues so
you know when to to jump back in.
But really I want anybody in everywhere
to be able to engage with us today.
So, let's go to exercise number 1.
I like to think of this as big dreams,
blue sky, so write, think, type along.
And especially for those of you who
might not know what comes next or
are still exploring,
thinking through this process,
a question that we'll ask you, we asked
this in our past information session.
If there were no preconceived
notions of what success looked like,
if there were no fear of failure, if there
was anything you could do in your life,
ask yourself,
what is it that you really want to do?
This will be followed by two
minutes of free writing.
But before we go there, I want to
give a little bit more detail here.
So when you're asking yourself
what it is you really want to do,
that doesn't necessarily have
to be just a job or a title.
Maybe its an impact, or
maybe it is some space in the world
that you want to inhabit.
You can think about this broadly and
that's where that big comes into play.
But take a moment and jot that down.
I'm going to give you about two minutes,
as you figure out what that looks like,
add some detail and color to that.
Try your best to fill out those two
minutes to give you as much detail
as possible.
I'm going to actually hop off screen,
I'm going to start that timer so
that you won't be distracted [LAUGH]
by my affirmative bubblehead.
So, go ahead, put that pen to paper.
We have two minutes, ask yourself,
what do I really want to do?
I will see in two minutes.
All right, go ahead and
complete those final thoughts.
I have been scanning the Q&A box and
I will get to that.
Today, we are going to be
focusing our attention on kind of
how do you craft that story,
what's the breadth?
And we are actually going to be
sharing some focus on the essays,
as well as interviews.
And what are some of these other platforms
and avenues for sharing your story?
What are some of those mediums?
Tomorrow will be Sharing Your Story,
Part Two, where we'll talk about
the written format, including essays.
And then Thursday's event will be in
spoken form, so think interviews and
networking.
So, just wanted to share
that as we move forward.
So let's unpack this
exercise a little bit.
So I drew a line here so
we can think about both the outcome,
as well as the process.
I love it when the image behind just
happens to work along with what we're
trying to do.
With the outcomes, we're thinking
blue sky, so let's start there.
Was your answer what you expected?
I know for
some folks who might be entering the space
with an idea of what they want to do.
Did it end up being the same thing that
you were thinking about earlier once you
were released of all
of those expectations?
Was there a little bit of extra nuance,
or depth,
or this new angle on it that
kind of piqued your interest?
From here, ask yourself two things, right?
Why did you answer this?
What is it about,
whatever it is you wanted to do,
what is it that spoke to you?
Okay, from there, okay.
How might those things infuse my
goals whether that is career goals,
life goals, personal professional
while at business school.
So taking that time to sit back and
reflect, so these might be topics
used to journal have conversation on,
but I also want you to think
not just about the outcomes, but
take a look at that process.
One of my favorite questions to ask during
exercises like this is, how did that feel?
Right?
Paying attention to both
your body your reactions.
When was it hard or when or where
because sometimes there might have been
a topic there might have been a direction.
You might have been stymied after you
got to a certain point in adding detail.
How was it hard?
Was it difficult because you
couldn't find the words?
Was it difficult because
you're still learning and
thinking through it all are valid reasons.
And offer an opportunity for
you to think okay,
maybe this is an area to further explore.
And it might have been easier, and
those might be the channels where
that could be a place for you to look at
to drive some of these inspirations for
what might be down the pipeline for
you, okay.
So we did a little bit of writing, but
I know there are folks out there
who process in different ways.
So we're going to do something else.
I like to call this, speak your truth,
and you might have a little
inkling of what it might be given
the highlighting in the title.
Sometimes it's easier to talk to people.
And I know this might feel strange
especially given that we are engaging
across potentially continents and seas and
sharing space in a virtual setting.
And I also recognize that not everybody
might be in an environment where they're
able to do this.
So if you're able to please join in, if
you're not kind of engaged mentally, but
what we're going to do is I want you to
choose one of these six questions, right?
My other favorite question is,
tell me more.
So what we're going to do, is I'm going to
set another timer for two minutes.
This time I'm going to stay on screen.
It might feel weird, but I encourage
you to answer that question to me live,
talk your way through it.
We might not know each other
kind of personally, but
I hope by now you know that I really
am kind of here in your best interest.
I'm here to support you in the process and
I really do want to get
to know you better.
So, we're about to start.
So let me get my timer ready.
For those of you who are again
watching this across time and space,
you can watch me, you can put it on pause,
you're talking to a static image.
Or if you want to challenge yourself,
you can set it to pause and
use five minutes, as your time.
The challenge here is
to use the entire time.
You might be surprised,
as you talk your way through it,
what some of the answers and
some of the directions you might take.
So, here we go.
Hey, that sounds like a really
awesome thing that you want to do.
I'm really curious about it.
What is it about it that
really speaks to you?
Can you tell me more?
We have about two minutes.
So yeah, the floor is yours.
Keep going tell me more
All right, if you have reached
the end of your statement, awesome.
If you're still finishing up
your thoughts, thank you so
much for
sharing some of your inspiration and
the direction you're thinking about
what really resonates for you.
So, and actually,
as we step back from the exercise,
I do think you if you engage with that.
I think being able to verbalize, and talk
your way through things is also going to
be one of those really important skill
sets that you're going to need to develop.
And are going to be able to develop
both during this application process,
as well as during your
time in business school.
It's going to be a skill set that
you're going to be using for
your entire career and lifetime beyond.
So as we close that exercise as well,
think through these same six questions.
Did the answers go in a direction
that you were expecting?
Why, why not?
What were the things that spoke to you?
How did that feel?
Was it difficult?
What parts were difficult?
And I know for everybody,
there's going to be a different
comfort level with speaking out loud.
So as you use both that written format,
as well as the verbal format for
thinking and processing.
I hope you're able to
find some happy medium,
that allows you kind of the most efficacy,
and kind of blank canvas,
to paint that big picture
of what it means for you.
All right,
what is it that you really want to do?
I think that is a great
bottom line question.
And now we're going to
transition to looking backwards.
So we did a little projection forwards,
now it's about looking backward.
And this is one of those pieces again to
the Stanford application process that will
often take a little bit more
time than you might expect.
So, exercise number two,
I call this centering yourself.
So it's going to be pretty simple.
So I want you to complete the sentence.
This first part shouldn't
take too long and
you'll be able to whisk
through pretty quickly.
So, I am, blank.
A figure in my life is or was, blank.
Blank, was an important moment or
place in my life.
So, for me, I am Filipino American.
A figure in my life is my friend
Zen Zen and if you're out there Hi,
hope you're doing okay and
The veterinary clinic that was
my first job out of college was
an important moment or place in my life.
So hopefully that easy go through and
scroll in just whatever comes top of mind,
okay.
This next piece,
I'm actually not going to make time bound.
The next question and
can the next step here,
I want you to be able to take as much time
as you need to explore, think and process.
And that processing is where a lot of
the time is probably going to be invested.
That processing will include connecting
the dots between these blank lines,
these three words that you filled in,
and who are you?
So, because of you,
I want you to address each one of
your answers as if it was a person.
So I am Filipino American,
because of being Filipino American,
I am, talk about yourself.
Think about some of the identities that
belong to you whether it is kind of
immediately visible, maybe it's
something that is just kind of seen and
known by you, maybe it's one
of these invisible identities.
How does that affect the way
you move through the world?
When it comes to the people in
the space that you're inhabiting,
how have they shaped your life,
how have the places you've been?
The incidents or events, the different
things that happen in your life that may
be pivotal in shaping the perspective that
you're going to bring to business school.
What might some of those be?
And that just what are they?
But really the focus of this exercise is,
who are you because of them.
So this could be a wonderful
exercise to do for journaling,
maybe it's something you're
talking to friends with.
I do want to take a little time out to
talk about self care and mental and
emotional wellbeing,
not just for this exercise but
in this application process and
in business school.
There is going to be a lot
of stress as part of this.
Part of the hope for application week
is to alleviate some of the stress and
anxiety but it is also an inherent
part of what we're doing.
Take time for self care.
For this exercise in particular,
sometimes the answers that you are going
to come up with might cause duress
they might be triggering, they might
kind of have you exploring in ways where
you might need additional support.
I really encourage you to kind of
prepare for that, take time and
also find the support that you need.
If that is professional and
help I encourage you to find the tools,
resources and
people in your life who can set you up so
that you can thrive in
whatever settings you're in.
So just wanted to take a moment
acknowledge that this can take you in
a lot of different directions.
We are here for you and
there is help we want you to thrive.
Now, putting it back together,
we're going to come back to
your journey a little bit.
I know we started with,
hey, what is a story?
It's an expression of your motivation for
business school.
And it's a foundation for
you to have many connections,
build some many relationships with
the different people that you're
going to be interacting with
throughout this entire journey.
That's why today we're stepping
back from just the kind of close
view of applications of the essays
to understand the story writ large.
Because as you start to move
into the written portions and
the spoken elements of the journey,
you're going to be drawing from the story
you're going to be looking left and right.
And being asked to identify different
parts of that landscape that you've
traversed so far, and
what the future looks like or
what you hope it looks like ahead.
What is that horizon for you?
Through that one of the most effective
ways to connect with individuals,
whether it's written or in person, or
virtually, is to find something in common.
And something that each and
every one of us has in common is
that we have a lived experience.
Those experiences might be different.
But as you find some of
those commonalities,
those are the moments
were able to connect.
And oftentimes those commonalities
are when you're able to dig deeper and
really think about, again and this is
going to sound really overarching, but
some of these questions will have you
thinking about stuff that is inherent to
the human condition.
I bet you didn't think we're going to be
talking about the human condition and
I was like stories, and
business school applications.
And yes, this is a school application.
But this is also an opportunity to do
a little bit of designing your life,
thinking about what are the things
that are important for you?
How might those guide the next steps,
whether that is educational professional,
personal, the intersection of all of those
as well as plot the course that your
future might take, right?
Let's think big,
let's aspire, let's dream.
And from there let's look for
the tools and
experiences that can help you
achieve just those things.
Let's celebrate that squiggly
line of how you got to today and
embrace that squiggly line of
exploration that dotted and
dashed line because that story and that
journey, that trail has yet to be blazed.
So center yourself in this.
All right, and I promise we're
going to do some takeaways tips.
Really get into some of
the tactical practical and
we'll transition into
the Q & A box from here.
And I do apologize ahead of time, I do.
You'll notice I tend to shy
away from heavy text slides.
But here I think it's going to be
helpful for us to have a platform, and
something to anchor our conversation.
So, three broad themes here I'm going to
talk about, you are the expert in you.
Your story is always evolving and
remember,
think about it as a story and
your story and not a script.
Let's dig into these
a little bit more deeply.
So, I often get asked the question,
hey will I'm still exploring,
I'm kind of not sure what I'm going
to do next in business school,
how much detail do I need
to have in the application?
And for the Stanford just the application
as you're thinking about how much
resolution do I need in my goals?
You will notice that the short term
long term goals section is actually
pretty short.
We're asking you more in our big essays
what matters the most to you and why and
why Stanford, right.
Maybe your short term long
term goals are implicit and
really informed why Stanford, but
you're the center of that, right?
So the only person you need to
convince that this is a relevant,
meaningful kind of step in
your life is you, right.
Your answer is the only one that matters.
I'm not going to be judging whether or
not kind of your path is possible, or
whether you're going to be hirable, or
an attractive candidate
within any given industry.
Because we trust that during
your time at Stanford,
you're going to be equipped to thrive
where ever you might end up afterwards.
And honestly you're probably
going to end up doing at least one
pivot Geography industry function at
some time during business school and
most definitely beyond.
We're not going to hold you
to anything you write down.
And that's where some of that evolving
story comes into play, right?
Allow yourself to embrace the new
experiences that you come to.
But as you're going through this,
okay that thing happened in my life or
there's this person, how do I know what
content or what topics to bring in?
Is there anything that's off
limits to talk about this process?
Again, speaking only for the Stanford GSB
experience, the answer is no.
How I would advise you around this is,
think about that someone.
What is it that you are trying to
convey through that example, right?
Sometimes the things where
your greatest learnings or
realizations come from might
be something controversial.
The ground rule here maybe is,
speak about it in good taste.
Provide the detail that is necessary for
us to understand it.
And if it's something extremely sensitive,
you also don't have to
say every single detail.
We trust you to share
what you want with us.
I know that sometimes there are analogies
out there about your story and
it needing to be so deeply personal that
you wouldn't want anybody else to see it.
That if you printed it out at work,
you would run there,
grab it off before anybody
got there in the morning.
Great, I hope there is some
kind of connection there.
And I don't want you to feel
like to have a compelling and
kind of meaningful story that you have
to have something that you're hiding or
that implies that there's something that
you might be a little embarrassed about.
If it's there and
you want to go there, let's do it.
But if it's something that gives you joy,
and
you actually talk about it all the time.
the way I think about it is, as long as
you have some connection to that story,
as long as there is some feeling that
you're communicating when you're
talking about,
what it is that you really want to do, or
here's how my past informed who I am
today, as long as there's that feeling and
connection, you are headed
in the right direction.
When it comes to the balance and space,
that's going to be different for
every setting you're in.
We'll talk about that a little bit
more in the other sessions this week.
But generally I would say, if you step
back and you spent more of that time or
written real essay on that person or
something other than yourself,
you might want to take that editing
eye and center yourself back in.
I want to learn about you.
I want to know who you are and
how you're going to show up in
our classroom and community.
And so that could be one way to guide you.
And you are the expert.
You are the one who lived
through all of this.
And we hope you're able to take maybe
some of these exercises we did today
to reflect and understand this
journey with that much more nuance.
I already talked about how your
journey is always evolving.
Allow yourself to incorporate these
learnings into the things that you
want to do next.
Maybe it just adds another detail and
kind of further evidence for
that path that you're pursuing.
Maybe it's getting you to turn a little
bit or kind of look in other directions.
I think all of those are powerful.
And all those are things that
are going to be important to you, and
can be guiding principles and
ways for you to decide,
when you have different options,
which one might you want to pursue.
Remember, reflect, process, connect.
Process and connect could be flipped
here but I figured, remember, reflect,
process, connect sounded a little
bit more like I would remember that.
So, remember the things in your life.
Remember the events, people, places,
achievements, things that you're proud of.
Reflect on that circumstance, right?
Not just that event, but how did you feel?
What were some of the situations and
circumstances surrounding it?
That process and connect piece, how did
that inform anything else in your life?
Are there connections here?
Because of that action, I learned.
And then, hey, in this other instance,
I applied that learning.
Or, hey, that was feedback,
now I'm seeing myself in new ways.
Now this is changing the way I'm
thinking about approaching maybe this
field that I'm interested.
And that all takes time,
be gentle with yourself.
Take time for that introspection.
Sometimes that introspection
can be done with others,
it doesn't always have to be solo.
Find people that you can care about.
Also think about who the mentors,
sponsors, and advocates in your life
might be, so that they can help advise and
guide you through this process and
give other valuable perspectives coming
from people who really care about you.
And then, remember, it's yours.
This belongs to you.
I'm trying to get us to think
about that big picture, right?
Think about that story as something
that you're able to adapt and
flex to different situations.
If you get stuck in a script and
we think about it as a script,
coming off of that page
becomes really hard.
But you are going to be in so
many interesting, fascinating and exciting
spaces, not just as you apply to business
school, but during your time there.
People are going to
want to learn about you.
Building these many relationships are
different ways that you can think about
networking or
kind of exploring career options, right?
So hopefully these tips and little tricks
can help you along the way as well.
And remember,
you don't have to tell the whole story.
Earlier I mentioned, some things,
we're still processing.
We're still trying to figure out
how that fits into the shape of me.
All right, that's awesome.
Take that time.
You own this.
We want you to tell us
what you want us to hear.
That's very different from,
what does Will want to to hear?
What do I think Will wants to hear?
Or what do I think Will wants
to read in an application, and
shaping your narrative to that.
Because you might lose
all of the different and
beautiful aspects of yourself when
you're trying to conform to what you
think might be someone
else's expectations.
You are the one who is able to
give us that nuance and detail and
insight into who you are.
I think this is a detail that I also
want to share, like, yes, there are a lot
of people out there, things, that I say,
hey, this is what got me in.
And for them, yes,
it might have helped them in this journey.
This is a holistic review process, so
we are looking at everything in context.
So in actuality, that may or may not
have been the thing that caught them in.
Even as we talk to our alumni and
our students, as awesome as they are,
they don't know why they got in and
they never will.
So, yes, be inspired,
kind of think through again,
these are some of the people I could
be learning and growing with, and
celebrate you, celebrate your journey.
They will also be learning
from you in turn.
No one can tell your
story the way you can.
Use your words, your language, the way
that feels and fits like a good coat,
like a good thing, so that when you
are submitting that application,
you know that you are giving us
the fullness of who you are.
So, with that, thank you,,
that was a lot of content.
I am going to turn to our Q&A box now.
I see that there's been a lot of action.
My colleagues have been answering
questions this whole time.
But if you haven't done so already,
I encourage you to start
MyStanford.mba account.
With some quick questions,
we're able to help collect events
that might be of interest to you,
as well as Application tracker to see
just where are you in the process.
Alright, let's stop share for a minute.
And let's go to the Q&A box.
Alright, so there is a little
bit of process question here.
So this is from Shannon there's,
it's been uploaded.
So question about the review process,
would there be a group of admission
officers reading the same application or
just one officer.
I asked this because I believe different
people will weigh different values goals
differently.
For example, an admission officer who has
a mother may resonate with a candidate who
talks about motherhood better
than a non mother officer.
If possible, could you share how you
would read our stories to make sure that
the personal difference in interpretation
would not bias your decision?
Thank you for this question.
I think this is one of those
things that in the admissions
process we take very seriously a large,
like, bias.
Yes, it's part of being human.
It's one of those things that have
helped us evolutionarily over history.
And, we're not in that fight for
survival anymore.
And sometimes these biases, which may
have been helpful in other instances,
may actually work against us in
the things that we're trying to achieve.
And in the application review process,
this is one where that bias,
you're right, it can play a difference
and, we do training around that.
And so
there are going to be multiple readers for
all the folks who are admitted, right?
We want to make sure that there are eyes
on kind of to ensure that we are doing as
fair and providing us fairs and
assessment as possible.
During our trainings, we do these
every year, we talk about bias.
What are some of the different things
that might influence the way you look at
an application?
Also it is an evidence based process.
As I was mentioning earlier, there
are elements where we're looking at past
behavior as a great indicator for
how you might behave again in the future.
That is one of the things
that we're looking at.
When we're looking and saying, hey,
here is an instance, here's evidence.
That those are the times that we're
able to make the strongest cases and
we see hey, yeah,
this is why you should be here at the GSD.
This is where that storytelling
element comes into play.
And I say that not as kind of trying
to adapt the story to cater to
the people in the room.
But rather, we are thinking and
looking for diversity broadly defined
as you are able to talk about who you are,
kind of to the fullest extent.
That's when our readers were trained to
kind of recognize the biases that we have
as humans and set that aside and
work with and
through them to make sure we see, okay?
Here's the journey for
this individual in context.
Your journey might look very different
from someone else's journey.
That doesn't mean yours is any more or
less difficult or appealing,
it just means they're different.
And we want to make sure we're thinking
through how you've expressed your voice,
talent and
made an impact in those settings.
So kind of to summarize that,
we take bias very seriously in
our evaluation and process.
We do have multiple folks who are going to
be having eyes on your application as we
move through the process.
And we really care that we are providing
an evidence based recommendation.
While we're kind of pulling together and
creating a diverse and
dynamic class with from
all types of backgrounds.
Okay, here's a question from Freddy,
about how you should split the essay,
should be 77% personal story and
the 30% professional experience?
Is there a general rule of thumb?
And so we'll talk a little bit more
about this in tomorrow's session.
But I think as you're trying to think
through kind of what elements of your
story will now be important,
take a look at the question itself, okay?
For some schools, there might be kind of
a recommendation for how you balance it.
At Stanford, there's not, you'll notice
that our questions are pretty open ended.
What matters the most to you and why?
That does not have to be career or
profession related,
we're really asking you
what matters to you.
And not just that, we're hoping that
you're doing some of the things we did
together today and
really dig into the how and
why to understand kind of the values and
perspective that you would bring.
So there is no recommended
balance necessarily.
You will notice that, there are questions
that are geared towards kind of that
professional experience.
So, the impact questions
that are optional.
If you aren't already
discussing things there,
that could be a place where you're talking
about work or kind of community or other
types of impacts that you might have made
in the different spaces you would have it.
So, each question might be
slightly different, but
we are very intentional
about the way we word it.
So we're not trying to fish for
some invisible proportion,
we're really asking directly for
the things that we're looking for.
So, hopefully that helps, and again,
there's no right or wrong balance.
Everybody is going to kind of embrace and
engage with these questions differently.
And I encourage you to do so, right?
Do it in a way that feels right for you.
Here's a question from Bluesky.
Is Stanford more interested in
someone inspired to change the world?
Or is it equally possible for
someone who just wants to live a better
life through learning at Stanford?
I think this is also one of those nuances.
We talked a lot about change.
How are you going to, like change lives,
change organizations,
change the world, it's in our motto.
I say, that's very aspiration, right?
We hope that you're able to dream big,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that we
are looking specifically for folks who
are like, I need to go change the world.
Sometimes you may just want to change
your little corner of it, right?
Maybe it's those projects that
you're approaching at work.
Maybe it is how you are moving
through your career and
you want to be able to accelerate that and
change that trajectory.
Those are all equally powerful,
relevant and valuable, like rationales for
coming to Stanford.
And so we don't have a preference for
whether you want to change the world, or
you just want to change the way you kind
of see things and kind of shake things up.
Your rationale is your own,
and I personally encourage you
to celebrate and
really live into those, okay?
And here's another question about,
how would you advise on making
cliche topics interesting?
So, for example, wants to go to Stanford
because of the tight knit network.
Center yourself.
We did a little bit of
that as an exercise.
But as you think about even
things like an answer,
maybe family matters the most to you,
why, why again?
What are some of the things that you as an
individual have experienced to shape that?
I think that question of why is so
powerful and
we'll play around with that a little
bit more in one of our other workshops.
But really digging in and getting deeper.
That's where that authenticity
piece comes to play.
You're the only one who can talk about
your life and the nuances of it.
And so allow yourself to go there.
I think it really does surprise people,
how like encompassing the journey is and
how much we're asking you to think about
things beyond just kind of that practical
tactical, this is what I'm
going to do with my career.
But also, here's who I am and this is how
that informs how I'm going to show up,
here there in any other setting.
So, I do want to be respectful
of everybody's time.
Thank you so much.
We will be going through these questions
and saving a number of them to ask Dimas
this Friday,
[LAUGH] office hours with the Dimas.
I think hearing from her is also
an amazing way to learn about kind of
the philosophy and
energy and the spirit of the GSB,
MBA application review process.
So, thank you so much for
sharing in this afternoon, morning,
evening whatever time of day it is,
thank you for spending this time with us.
Hopefully you were able to take something
useful away, maybe it was a trick,
activity, awareness, whatever it may be.
I hope to cross paths with you again soon.
Until then, thank you again, stay safe.
And here is the creating your story.
[MUSIC]